I simply rationally don't understand
what Israel is doing yes Hamas has to be
anihilated but the way Israel is doing
it with exploding number of so-called
collateral damage children and so on can
you even imagine what this is doing to
anti-Semitism what a new Boost this is
giving to
anti-Semitism individual people are
fascinated by images you are bombarded
daily by people suffering in Gaza
children suffocating or by tragic
details that for example now I read this
in a western media that children who are
still in Gaza now cut their name into
their skin so that if they are found
death they can be identified